I think that respect for men within our
society today is more so tied to what
that man can provide in the utility
within that like short story so um
before I started on YouTube I consider
myself a hobbyist and so one of the
things that I did prior to turning the
video camera on myself is to become a
photographer now at the same time you
know I was a post MBA working a
six-figure job at a fortune whatever
company but I wanted to do photography
so I eventually started to like book
gigs within that one of the gigs that I
booked it was at like a wedding party or
something like that and then I'm having
a conversation with a young woman at the
wedding party I saw a kind of looking I
saw a kind of shoes and decided to walk
up and have a conversation with them and
like the low level barometer of
disrespect
uh just based off of oh so you like is
this what you do like this little
photography thing I was like oh you
dirty dirty wench